are you a planner and organizer yes I am
definitely a planner and organizer I
think that's what I'm probably most
fulfilled doing is planning organizing
which I guess makes sense because in a
sense that's what a screenplay is just a
an organized plan for an emotional
journey
you know I'm constructing a essentially
a train that the audience is going to
ride and I'm planning out every little
Manute detail of that ride and then
trying to hide the audience from the
rails in the car and I'm using empathy
as a misdirection for that so I like
knowing the destination and then
constructing the path to it and then
sort of hiding that path for the
audience and so do you always know the
ending when you start writing a story I
always know the anyone I start drafting
when I first am thinking about a story I
don't necessarily know the ending and
I'm scribbling a bunch of notes what
might be the ending what might be a
scene I'm I do a lot of note-taking and
a sort of loose free thought of what
whatever that I'm interested in this
project I'm just trying to collect as
much as possible out of my brain about
what's interesting me about that thing
and then I'll do a treatment and I'll do
that treatment over and over and over
until it gets to a point where I feel
like that's the story I want to write
and then I'll go to a draft so by the
time I'm going to a draft I know the
ending but I also know everything
leading up to it and so my first drafts
I can usually write pretty quick but
that's because I just spent months
writing a treatment over and over and
over and it's different versions and I'm
tweaking different little things
so that everything as a whole is fitting
together so in the draft I can have a
lot of room to explore those nooks and
crannies particular when it comes to
those character I do sing Chrissy's and
just little lines of dialogue because I
know that as a whole this story will
arrive at this natural conclusion or
what should feel like a natural
conclusion
obviously I've contrived it but I feel
good that I've set up the pieces so that
it will necessarily arrive there and not
elsewhere do you think planning and
organizing is one of your strengths or
are there times you wish you could be
less of a planner ah there are times
when I wish that i was a little bit
freer in my writing I started taking
improv classes as a tool to be less in
my head and more present and just open
to possibilities and it's been really
helpful both personally and then also in
my writing interesting okay because you
would think most writers would have the
opposite problem where they were just
you know that they just wouldn't they
weren't able to get on task and so I
find that interesting I think that I try
to I try to plan the times in which I'm
freely thinking so plan so I'm still
planning but in in my notebook I'm
saying all right I'm gonna just freehand
write this scene and I don't know if
it's gonna be in the movie I don't even
know who these characters are sometimes
it's just like character a character B
but I'm just writing whatever because it
doesn't have to exist within the film
yet so there's a little bit of a freedom
there that allows me to just explore
different things and then when I'm
taking that notebook which has a bunch
of different things I'm looking through
all right what after months of doing
this what am I still responding to what
am I still interested that scene that
actually I thought I was interesting
that but I'm not and so it's good
because I don't have to I don't I'm not
wasting time in the draft of writing
that scene when
has to fit into a larger structure of
the screenplay I have that more
abstractly so I've planned that time to
do that and to like let myself free
associate and just kind of see where
characters and lines of dialogue and set
pieces and everything is going and then
taking that into a treatment I get to
pick and choose and now yet to organize
all these thoughts that I've collected
you